[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm link and
I'm Rhett I did a tit syllable Rhett you
wanted to stretch it out I think why you
got a notice joining us this week at the
realm table of dim lighting link I'm so
excited I'm so excited we have a bona
fide real-life paleontologist bone
digger we did it man we're gonna meet a
paleontologist he's so excited I mean
this this is uh this is at your request
yeah and I'm excited to just be here and
and watch your bubble be burst no I
don't we haven't talked to her yet you
know this is it's my dream job it's my
backup yeah he said Who oh she is dr.
Emily Lindsey she is currently stationed
at the La Brea Tar Pits
III local I don't mean burst in your
when I say burst your bubble I just
think your expectations of like this is
the best job on earth don't tell me
anything don't I don't worry her to
bring you back down to like you know
excavation level you know the best job
owner buy that by the end of our
conversation we don't know yet because
they haven't had it that the operative
question is how are you gonna feel about
it are you are you are you abandoning
our efforts here in order to tag along
with her without pay or are you gonna
are you gonna just say alright I'm happy
for you but I realize it's not my
calling anymore it isn't unknown at this
point we'll see because see how it turns
out we have already talked to the person
to the guest and then we record the
intro we're mixing it up or recording
intro before we talk to the guest so I
am so mixed up we carpooled into work
today and as happens many times we begin
a conversation that then but nope I'm
not gonna tell you about that I'll tell
you about that during the podcast yeah
because we keep it real for you guys we
don't like to have conversations we've
already had we don't recreate
conversations who does that we're moving
at the speed of real conversation here
so what was the first oh this is what
you said you were like
there was a lull in our convo and then
all of a sudden you threw out there I
almost got in a fight with somebody on
the street mm-hmm and before I could
perk fully up and be like what what you
were like but but save it for later so
let me have it
because yeah I mean loyal ear biscuit
ear we did we discuss this and we
discussed how we would approach in each
type of road rage situation moving
forward right I definitely believe that
it factored in if you were the one that
has happened to oh god that you may not
be standing you're sitting here with me
no really yeah it got that intense what
okay so where was I I was driving by
myself as I like to do that explains why
I don't remember this and I was on the
west side don't make it over there that
often but I am driving along and I'm on
Hollywood Boulevard for some reason like
it was sending me I was going to the
west side like around UCLA area but
that's highfalutin there it was sending
me not on the 405 like the 101 to the
405 but it was sending me to Hollywood
Boulevard sounded like an episode of the
Californians and then like through town
like basically if you're gonna take
probably with it just trust yeah I mean
I'm trusting the navigational system
that's but that's what they call the
surface streets surface streets yes
there's a lot to see but there's also a
lot more decisions to be made about like
oh because it's you know la is one of
those places where you'll get up to this
intersection and all of a sudden they'll
be like four options as opposed to just
like a left and a right and a straight
there's also like another road that's
kind of like all that they connected
that road to so is what that was that
intersection like on Sunset somewhere
where there's low are you talking about
the like no no no there's that really
famous one not the one with like eight
roads that come into it no
stop lying stop lighter a bird's eye
view of that intersection and basically
resident of Beverly Hills a bird's-eye
view of that is it looks like a dag on
asterisk with in everybody has a stop
sign
but no there's no light there's no light
us go and navigate what is it that it's
literally that many rows coming together
it was it was a normal light but I get
up there and I realized that I'm in the
turn lane to go left which would send me
down one of those squirrely roads and I
actually wanted to go not like left left
or left but just halfling I wanted to go
left but was it was technically straight
because it was a left turn but it wasn't
as left as the it's one of those weird
yes yeah so I'm in the left turn lane
and I'm already like I feel like I'm
gonna be late to where I'm going which
is another story for another time where
I'm going well this makes that statement
right there makes you wrong this is all
your fault now you've just admitted to
that just by saying I was late no I
think that means this is your fault but
don't tell me it's just now I'm
predicting that no matter what happens
in this story
mmm it was your fault I think we're
because you were late I think we're both
at fault for the initial incident so I I
have my left how many hits it is when I
left blinker on to turn left but then
the people going straight get the green
light mm-hmm okay
and they start going and I'm thinking is
there gonna be an opening rock and pull
out of the left lane and get back into
the straight lane and goes through the
intersection mm-hmm and I'm like looking
in my rearview mirror side mirror and I
see dude that dude totally lagging like
that dudes texting or something mmm he
left me like a five-car gap like oh look
it wasn't even like that is nice it
wasn't even pulling out it was like he
was asked me like oh cool
come on cuz I have my blinker on mmm
only goes right it's like on a platter
so oh you you switched your black guru
switch my blinker to the right to let
people know I'm trying to get over this
guy texts boy is giving me this big gap
text boy gives you a big gap you take
advantage of the gap oh yeah so I pull
in and I'm like home free are you
skirt what I did not see was a
motorcycle oh no oh man I don't know but
because he was behind Tex boy and he saw
the gap and he was splitting lanes as is
it is illegal to do that in California
as is done so he so basically I get out
there and he's making up the difference
behind text boy and this is coming
around text boy yeah what ends up
happening is as I basically get
completely into the lane and up to speed
he gets right beside me like continuing
to split the lane but he's mad on the
passenger side while the passenger side
but he's mad because I just did what I
did right because I pulled back into the
I don't think I did anything illegal I
just did something that was kind of
unexpected and quick and we on a
motorcycle you're sensitive to those
things which I recognize but he was so
mad that I had done this did he have how
did you tell he was so mad well just
wait so as I'm going he comes up next to
me and is like literally like it felt
like what he was trying to do was like
trying to tap me with his leg like with
his bike like trying to initiate contact
with me to like basically say like you
did that and then you hit me but
actually I really hit you but I'm trying
to make it like you hit me oh really
you thought he was he was taking taking
a fall but I had no idea that I mean I
didn't feel anything he just got really
close to me then he pulls out in front
of me and turns around and like waves
and says pull over pull over
like just dude and like a leather jacket
what kind of bike like he's not like a
crotch rocket but he looked like he was
like ready to race you know
mmm-hmm full helmet full helmet but good
but glasses that I could see his clear
glasses didn't have a visor like glasses
like what not what you have on but
glasses I could see his eyes spectacle
and he's turning around he's like pull
over and he gets so slow he gets down to
like one
an hour and I'm stuck and I can't go and
I'm right up on him and all these people
start honking he's like trying to take
me down and take me off for the road are
you kidding me
yeah and so I'm thinking lots of things
I'm thinking I'm a lover not a fighter
I'm a big guy but I probably don't
actually want this to come to blows how
do i defuse this situation at the time I
had no idea what he was thinking I think
he was just mad and he wanted to like
pull me over and tell me off what are
you thinking so this goes on for a
couple of minutes like slowing down
traffic and getting me to pull over I'm
just like just continuing just I got my
sunglasses on I'm just like continue to
go like 1 mile an hour not stopping
thinking like I'm gonna pull I'm gonna
try to get around him or something like
I don't wanna do anything rash that
would suddenly like hit him you know so
I'm giving giving him space so then you
giving him a gap he did you shake your
head no look no no then we come to a
stop sign I stopped a stoplight oh yeah
at that point I come to a stop and he
comes up he backed up he came back up I
was like I'm gonna I don't care I'm not
scared so he like stops and I like pull
out right beside him and I roll my
window down yeah cuz I was like I'm
going to engage as I in a human way here
right now
roll down the window and I just kind of
look at him I know you lived and he says
you hit my leg you hit my leg hit an
accent that I couldn't place you hits my
leg that's irrelevant and I'm just
giving you full ok pictures here and
then he said you hit my leg when you
pulled out or something like then I was
like I was like how am I gonna play this
because I definitely did not hit his leg
if anything he hit me and he's trying to
it's like one of these insurance things
where he's oh totally left out the whole
time he got behind me he took all these
pictures of my car in my license plate
and then he got in front of me and
turned around and took pictures with me
phone you blot so he took law he's got
lots of pictures of me with his phone
and then when when I stopped and he said
that thing you hit my leg he was taking
a bunch of pictures he said you hit my
leg I'm taking pictures I've took her
pictures I took I got pictures of you
as you're saying as you're talking to
him yeah but then I was like what am I
gonna say because I'm not gonna admit
that I hit his leg because I didn't you
should have been like dude take video
I'm let's put this on record but then I
said hey man you're gonna like piece the
pictures together to form like a
stop-motion animation of your defense
yeah I said hey man I am really really
sorry about this about what hitting his
leg mmm I said I said admit it I said
I'm really sorry that I that I pulled
out into that Lane I didn't see you
because I was just like what am I gonna
do because he wasn't doing video or
anything I was like what can I do to
just get out of this situation yeah and
he was like what you hit my leg and then
I was like you know I don't I don't
think I hit your leg I think you ran
into me but less you had already
apologized but I was like but listen for
something I'm really really sorry that
this had to happen that this happened
but it did have to happen and and then
he looked at me and II was just like
shook his head and sped off oh you got
it were you thinking about our podcast
conversation it for a split second at
all you were like I can't I can't
after lecturing the linkster I knew I
could not this road rage matches level I
can't match this brought it down I
brought it down I think that at the time
no I know Lee no I just naturally knew
that that was how I was going to this
engage you gotta give me a little credit
did you learn from wrote it down and I
came in apologizing not admitting guilt
and it apology guns blazing and also
basically calling him out and saying uh
yeah I think you hit me
soso you know I was letting to know that
I had a difference of opinion about this
did he he was he ever yelling did he
give you a level that you could have
matched she was very mad but it was no
he was he was talking aggressively yeah
I would have matched his level I would
have not I have not learned the lesson I
felt it as you're telling the story and
I think that have been like you've been
like why are you yelling but I'm just
matching your level and then I would be
like oh did I just say that again I
would have been worried about you I
would have been worried about you
because he man I wish I was there he's
seen it all off I wish I was there
because it it would have been what I
needed
it's like the one time
there is the time I needed to be there
so that we could have tested like you
didn't need to be tested this was you
said I mean nobody just proves that it's
like you're telling the story I don't
know I don't need to prove that you're
right it proved that my theory works in
action well I I agree with it what I'm
trying to prove is that I'm a different
person based on the conversation so I
can see us right now it's like he's up
there and I'll be like man ball up
beside him role in it or you be like all
right here yeah I'm gonna pull up beside
him I ain't scared you shouldn't be
scared but don't match his level I'm
gonna roll the window down here's your
chance link go in apologizing apology
guns-a-blazing you disarmed him yeah but
I still don't know if I'm gonna get some
sort of like letter from the cops I
don't know can you like take a picture
of somebody pursue it they can't prove
that you did it I don't think I have
that much faith in oh I have my whole
story ready well I'll tell you I had I
usually have video these notice I didn't
do anything illegal and he ran he came
up and ran into me and then said I ran
into him and first of all no one ran
into anybody cuz he didn't do and
there's no contact I mean he may have
brushed my car with his pant leg but
that's not hitting his leg but anyway
wherever you're at motorcycle man you
know I'm sorry I'm sorry we couldn't
work things out you've already
apologized
don't apologize again yeah I didn't hit
you man don't grovel you hit me if
anything hey guys if you want to support
entertainment the way to do that is to
go to mythical dot store and get some of
this merch you got to merch it up we've
got these ear biscuits jars that they
just look they're so drinkable it's like
biscuits so drink up whisk it bad are
made into a jar we've also got brand new
good mythical logo action look at that
shirt Navy t-shirt with orange what a
sharp and black hoodies with the good
mythical puddi a logo on the front and
the back double w money Cody wants one
yeah look he's got he's got the old G mm
honey honey he's got the old D mm honey
mythical dot store now it's time to to
gear up for the conversation with the
doctor of bone big game let's have it
[Music]
what did they tell you when they reached
out to you and said that we wanted to
talk to you was it like weird like hey
these guys these guys want to like
question you incessantly about
paleontology get it every day of the
week all the time I mean how many people
so what you're saying is is that my
personal interest in paleontology and
the my impression that it would be a
dream job it's just something that is
just mmm it's not it's not that uncommon
a lot of people have that illusion yeah
illusion now wait it's romanticize I
mean you should go out of the way give
her the full context of your your
admiration just what in your brain what
is this what is this like when I think
of this is like a big moment for you it
is because I don't think I've ever
actually besides like at a museum had a
legitimate conversation with a
paleontologist but I've spoken often
about how much I want to be one I have
now you tell me where I'm wrong I just
have this picture in my mind I mean I'm
in all khaki okay okay
okay first things first short sleeve no
no no no rolled-up sleeves khaki shorts
boots khaki socks for some reason in the
picture that I that I'm in and a hat
you've already said all khaki now you're
just kind of like saying the same thing
but more specifically and my beard is as
big as they can get and it's khaki and
it has because of the the Sun and the
being out there for the summer is turn
blonde and my skin is turn red and I'm
just out there patiently chipping or
brushing in that that's
a happy place I've never been to that
place I don't think I've ever worn a
khaki top and bottom together I don't
know if that's what you wear is that
your happy place and would you think it
would be my happy place and where am I
wrong it's pretty great um you probably
wouldn't have shorts on you'd probably
have long pants okay I knew that cuz
you're gonna be you know out in the
field it's it's rock sharp longers are
khaki they can be any color you want
that works um it's it can be hard it can
be boring it takes a certain type of
personality I think to want to sit you
know in the dirt all day and sort of
very slowly chip away at the rock but it
can be very zen-like I mean I feel like
people who surf kind of can get into
that zone and people you know who dig up
fossils can kind of get into that zone I
just pictured a surfer in all khaki I
never I've never pictured that before I
think cool we could start that my fear
is is that I had this picture but then I
would get bored and then and then be
like we should have brought that tall
guy like he thought he was gonna find a
t-rex on day one and look at him over
there talking to himself now yeah well
not a lot a khaki guy wants a lot day
like on his phone you think that would
happen I don't think you'd be on your
phone because you probably would not
very good cell phone reception that's
good so the zen-like part of it okay so
let's attach the the theory to some
practical reality here like when's the
first time you did this when it when did
it click into place for you like how do
you how do you how do you know that this
is what you want to do were you a hole
digger as a child no so I actually I
explicitly was pretty sure I didn't want
to be a paleontologist for most of my
educational career um I I was interested
in archaeology but I sort of came to the
conclusion that that was maybe people
were a little too messy so I didn't want
to I didn't want to do archaeology I
completely fell in love with ecology
when I was in college and decided that
that was what I wanted to do the
direction I wanted to go because it
works with systems and I really
that sort of Integrative system-level
nature of like oh here are all these
things that are living together and
here's how they're interacting with each
other and with their environment and if
you change one aspect of that of you
take away a species you had a new
species you change the temperature you
change the precipitation what does that
do to that whole system I found that
really compelling and I actually became
a marine biologist for a while that's
like everybody else's dream job just
like going from one dream job to the
next so every kid wants to be you're
picturing like riding dolphins no I'm
not talking about SeaWorld man I'm
talking about like if you go if you pull
a class of your first graders animal an
ocean life 56% of the class will want to
be a marine biologist 28 percent of the
class will want to be a paleontologist
but none of them follow through with it
except you and and the other people who
did which is pretty awesome because most
people don't and then what did you end
up doing as a marine biologist she wrote
on dolphin he did in yes I didn't I
actually I studied in vertebrates like
squishy little things you can barely see
that live underwater but I got to scuba
dive for a living for a few years and
that was great and I got to go to
Antarctica and work there which was
great so I had some great experiences
you scuba diving in Antarctica how thick
is a wetsuit in order to be able to miss
a dry suit man it is a dry suit yeah
that's right look at that we just I just
dry suited you haha I know a thing or
two about scuba diving rning he can't
prey on the continent I can't pronounce
it but I know I've seen I've watched us
go red channel a few times what how cold
do you get in your dry season so full
disclosure I actually wasn't scuba
diving in Antarctica I scuba dive in New
England but I did get to work in
Antartica off of a boat you're going in
and getting like a picture of the way
things are at the time that you're there
you may not necessarily know exactly
what you're contributing but you're
bringing this data back that then
someone is like running it against this
this you know over this 30-year period
and being like well this is this is you
know they're finding this mini
what's your my call it's in a in this
area and that's how it's changing pretty
much yeah and and this is what they're
eating and this is how fast they're
growing and how many babies they're
having and all of those different things
and so you know I was there for the
small time slice of this much larger
picture somebody's like well the birth
rate of whatchamacallit has gone down
with every degree that the earth is
heated up things I see I could do this
man
I just you just throw in you put
something and instead of watching McCall
it's and right it's that easy I'm
staying out of this so but how did you
move from marine biology to paleontology
was there something that like made you
jump tracks like was there a moment of
inspiration yeah there were there were a
couple of moments one was I sort of
became a little bit disenchanted with
marine biology not as a discipline but I
felt like the type of research I was
doing was a little bit narrower than
what I wanted it was um I mean there's
nothing wrong with that I mean it was
really important research but I have a
lot of interests I'm a really sort of
integrative person and I just I wanted
something a little bit broader um and
then you know throughout like college
people have been telling me hey like
dead things cuz you go on all these
archeological digs but you also like
animals you should be a paleontologist
and I would say no that's just people
like describing new species of dinosaurs
I don't think that's really interesting
that's not that's not where I want to go
but then I was working at this site in
Patagonia in southern Chile and it was a
cave site and it had some of the
earliest human skeletons in South
America it had like eleven human
skeletons buried in this cave that were
around 10,000 years old and we also had
bones of extinct giant mammals in the
cave the coolest one being one of my
favorites the giant sloth so there are
all these all these giant sloth bones in
the cave and there's this question of
were the humans at this cave site at the
same time the megafauna we're living
there these these big extinct animals
eating giant sloths maybe
that was one of the questions and and
also you know it's for you there when
they discovered it or did you show up
I showed up later which is still
exciting just to see that I mean though
some of the oldest humans in South
America you said some of some of the
earliest skeletons in that region yeah
because people didn't get down there to
that part of the world until like ten
thousand years ago or so actually um
some of the earliest sites we have in
the Americas are in South America the
oldest one being about 14,500 but we
don't have skeletons there we just had
sort of evidence that people people were
living there right um but there's been
this like debate in paleontology and
archaeology for more than half a century
now of why don't we have any of these
cool big animals around anymore so you
know if you think about like the African
savannah right like what do you think of
you think of the giraffes and you think
of elephants and rhinos CACI think of
the zoo right so what most people don't
realize is that until about between 10
and 50 thousand years ago pretty much
every continent on Earth looked like
Africa right so at 450 million years
there have been a lot of big animals on
all the continents on earth so but not
that at all are like savanna but that at
all
Savannah's that it all had big animals
crawling around yeah and I throw out a
layman's theory and then you tell me if
I'm right or wrong
you bet so the reason that those animals
are still in Africa is because they
co-evolved with the people there but all
these other big animals that you find in
North America they evolved and then
modern man showed up and killed them all
that is one of the theories good job
yeah let's just dry suit let's just pipe
down a little bit dry suit boys back I
won't keep - I'll keep doing that if I
have an idea I'll throw it out yeah no
that's that's that's good that's why
that's why you're not on the same page
he's not gonna hire you for this is not
a job you don't know man the Internet is
a fickle freakin place
oh well I mean if you want it if this
ends with you like tail between legs
following her into the digs then so be
it
I'm not threatened tell them between my
khaki legs yeah okay but wait you what's
the other idea so there were two things
happening at that time right so one of
them you're absolutely right humans were
spreading out across the world evolved
in Africa and then you know somewhere
around 60,000 years ago maybe a bit
earlier started heading out of Africa
into Eurasia and then down to Australia
and eventually over to the Americas and
you do see on a lot of these continents
those extinctions often coinciding with
the arrival of humans on those
continents and on major islands - so
like Madagascar until about 3,000 years
ago had giant lemurs on it and then
humans show up and they all about
extinct why we got to just kill big
stuff it's like the big sloth like 20
feet tall is it wasn't it like that big
there were some that big yeah
like I mean I understand looking
something low and connecting to be
brought down I want to eat that man but
then why doesn't the other guy be like
yeah but don't we won't also want to
have it like to see okay let's see that
one but let's not eat that one like I
can't do this not eat them all why we
got to eat everything you know there's
this idea that people have that like in
order to drive a species to extinction
humans have to go out and like hunt down
every single one and we don't actually
have to do that right like you just have
to kill a little bit more than her being
born mm-hmm
right haven't made his die off and then
they just die off it doesn't take that
long right so these people did not they
weren't thinking about ecology at the
time that was not that was not an area
of thought probably not and it'll pretty
recently but they bring it back to this
cave which really sparked your
paleontology shift I mean what what's
the what's the what's the conclusion or
the prevailing theory at this point with
why are all these it was at a burial
ground all these people dying and fallen
in a cave yeah it was a barrel around
Oh eleven of them huh right and when you
got there like how how excavated was it
are we talking like oh I can see like a
that arm sticking out there let's just
dust it whatever you do you know there
had been some excavations there I think
back in the 60s and then Chile had a
dictatorship for a while and the guy
that was in charge of the excavations
like a lot of the sort of academics and
intellectuals ended up fleeing the
country during the dictatorship and so
this was kind of the second round of
excavations they had decided to go back
and and do some more work there so it
was like half done it was yeah it was
partly done and then we went in and did
some more where the people like when you
show up is that I mean is that your what
you walk up to the edge or you walk you
go down in the cave and then there's
still you're still dusting and chipping
and pulling off out people yes that
seems pretty exciting
yeah and occasionally we'd find you know
new skeletons but this is you know
because they're underground I mean
they've died what eight ten thousand
years ago and so yeah they it's been you
know dust blowing into the cave and dirt
washing into the cave over thousands of
years how intelligent how intact to the
skeletons they were a complete pretty
complete complete yeah but I I guess
what I'm after is the most euphoric
moment I assume is when you discover a
new person like for you joining that
excavation like what what's what's the
most memorable moment well so for me I
think you know I come over here I don't
know what it is it like a party I don't
know yeah air horn right you hit the air
horn when you hit the new there are only
like eight of us so we don't really know
I'm gonna bring an air horn I'm sorry I
know what I'm gonna do a lot of tension
to myself when I find something new
because it feel like I want to make a
big moment out of it okay I think of
other options maybe they do make a big
moment that's my question well so for me
I mean you know you we got to the
because you were wondering when my aha
moment was and that cave was really my
aha moment was sort of realizing that
you could ask these ecology style
questions that I liked in ecosystems
that didn't exist anymore and give me an
example of it well so this question like
how did humans and these big animals and
the environment they were living in
interact and what does that tell us
about why there aren't that many big
animals around in North or South America
anymore and what might be happening
today when we have a lot more big
animals being kind of threatened with
extinction because the other factor you
know we talked about sort of this
hypothesis of humans coming and kind of
killing off the animals because they
were big and tasty and slow right um but
the other thing that was happening at
that time was climate change so we were
coming out of the last ice age and the
world was getting warmer you know it was
the last major episode of of global
warming you had these sort of opens
drier savanna ecosystems being
encroached on by forests which may not
have been as hospitable to some of these
animals that were there and so there's
been this kind of like debate and and in
some kind of some cases kind of
acrimonious antagonistic debate between
these two camps like the climate can't
than the human hunting camp I'm sort of
trying to figure out okay well we're in
a situation today where we've got you
know increasing human populations
industrializing societies increasing
pressures on the remaining wild lands
and we're in the middle of another major
climatic warming event so what can we
learn from this past event that happened
that might help us to not have a whole
bunch more big animals go extinct so are
you are you engaging in those kinds of
questions today like you can in this
main kind of you may get into like what
you're doing at the Tar Pits here but I
mean how much how much of your time is
spent looking at these things from the
past are you always making that
connection to the present day is that
actually is that just a personal thing
or is that like no that's actually part
of your discipline is making these
connections to today's situation so that
is that is a big part of my research
programs and they lend an increasing
number of paleontologists I would say
are sort of trying to use this deeper
time perspective of these really
long-term ecological changes to inform
our understanding of what's happening
today and inform conservation practices
even and that's something that you know
the liberate Harper that's where I am
now is really uniquely positioned to do
because we have the record of
essentially an entire ecosystem going
from you know 50,000 years ago through
the peak of the last glacial so major
global cooling and then major global
warming and the arrival of humans in the
Americas and this big extinction event
where 70 percent of the big mammals in
North America disappeared right and so
and we've both been to the Tar Pits and
took the took the tour I don't we took
the tour together know about it a couple
of times though but kind of explain this
the dynamics of why it's such a good
good spot and why there are so many so
many animals and so many intact
fossils there well and and first of all
I mean just for just the passing
experience it's like okay I'm just gonna
visit for just a few minutes you don't
have to go inside and you're like whoa
there's the thing that shocked me at
first it was like these aren't like
ancient Tar Pits like now it there's no
evidence of that that I could see with
the naked eyes like no there's a there's
a pond out there this that's like got
tar like black asphalt bubbling up out
of yeah there's also some fake woolly
mammoths in it yeah which is really cool
I'll catch you they I'm you go yeah I
was like real hey guys no airhorn
there's a mammoth emerging right now but
it's basically asphalt coming up out of
the the the depths to this day that
animals were falling into and and dying
so that you could dig them up later and
analyze them yeah pretty much
so but like so so that being said you
can go there and it smells like
someone's paving a road yeah it
literally smells exactly like still do
you still smell that all the time yeah I
do yeah you haven't adjusted yet no no
in fact you can so I used to work when I
was in graduate school I spent three
years excavating a tar pit site down in
Ecuador and when I started working at
the Tar Pits you know I would walk
through the park and be like it smells
like home smells like Ecuador I'm
excited I'm in the field you know even
though I spend most of my days these
days like inside my windowless office in
front of a computer like whenever I'm
out at the site like I just get that
kind of sense of excitement like I'm in
the field now what is the process of
getting something out of a tar pit
though I mean that's I mean that's not
like just going up to a you know a cave
and digging right I mean is you're
you're you like are you like digging
through the tar yeah so it depends you
know we have more than a hundred tar pit
deposits that have been found in the
park and and you know they're all a
little bit different so some of them are
super gooey like there's this big one
you can look down into called pit 91
that's like 59 for like 15 feet deep now
and and that's just very sort of liquid
and viscous and you can't actually step
in it or you would you know sink into
and so anyone excavating and it has to
be on these kind of catwalks that we
build over the top of it and they have
to either sit or lie on their stomachs
and and dig the asphalt out and and and
measure the bones out that way on the
other hand we have another set of
excavations that I in these giant wooden
boxes that we brought up when LACMA the
art museum next door was digging their
parking garage and they had to win to
get the fossils out so they could finish
building their parking garage this way
so you can see they're meticulously do
it right so I mean they took it out at
me in huge
cubes right right so they were found ten
years ago we're less than halfway done
with the fossils so you can imagine how
annoyed LACMA would be if we were if we
were down there ourselves doing it so
they yeah they they we heard a tree
boxing company and they brought him up
in these big wooden boxes I just like if
you were transplanting like a big oak
tree or a big palm tree and so we have
these like big takeout boxes of bones
that are all exactly in the same
position that they were when they were
deposited underground only we're
excavating them above-ground and that
those are older deposits and um and
they're much harder the the asphalt is
more oxidized and stuff so that it's
more like you know sort of a typical
paleontological say dinosaur dig where
you're you know hammering and chiseling
away the hard matrix to get the bones
out well but they were based they
basically just arbitrarily decided like
okay this is the grid we're gonna like
hack through this stuff or how did they
know where to cut because it's basically
like cubes so you're not cutting half of
a major find in you know cutting in half
or something
so they'd come down on it I mean you
know they were digging and you'd come
down on it either from the side or the
top and then you'd sort of feel around
and figure out where the extent of the
deposit was like how far did the bone
deposit go and then you know add some
extra buffer zone around that and and
that's where you build your box oh and
then they take that they put in the dirt
all around that that's not a deposit
they just excavated normally but then
they go on another thing let's box this
thing up yeah so you get fully intact
deposits that's crazy now what's the
craziest found has been this thing
that's been found in the box I don't
know that we found anything particularly
crazy or unexpected in the box so people
have been excavating the La Brea Tar
Pits like another mammoth
another saber-toothed tiger another what
yeah I'm that's you we get a lot of
those direwolves camels
we found some cool things so like Zed
are one of our more famous mammoths he
was found in one of these deposits and
he's one of the only
articulated specimens we have that's to
say we actually have almost all of his
bones and they're all kind of together
in the places they should be you don't
usually get that in a tar pit because in
the tar you have you know there's those
methane bubbles coming up and the tar
sort of oozy and gooey and you have
germs churning around that wasn't like
that Zedd would died and was washed into
a stream and then later the asphalt came
up and preserved his bone so you've
actually got him sort of laid out pretty
nice so that's that's a cool one that
we're able to you know really identify
oh this is all one animal and we can ask
questions about that animal and how he
lived and how he died and what he ate in
the environment he lived in that you
can't when you just have you know one
piece of bone one element what about
getting DNA from from these fossils like
what's the how old or how young does it
have to be before you can actually get
DNA so people have gotten DNA out of
fossils this old but nobody has ever
gotten DNA out of fossils from a tar pit
and we don't completely know why it
could be that the asphalt itself
destroys the DNA or it could be that the
types of chemicals and processes we have
to use to get the asphalt out destroys
the DNA but we've tried we have an
active project working on it but no luck
so far but the places that they've
gotten like the mammoth DNA do they have
like the whole sequence no I don't think
anybody has the whole sequence but a lot
of the mammoth DNA is coming out not of
bones per se but out of actual flesh of
mammoths that have been preserved in the
Arctic that are now thawing out right
yeah okay so you're not gonna typically
get that out of it you're gonna get it
when it frozen mammoth section right
yeah you think that they're gonna make
the mammoths there again they're gonna
bring it back because the dude that dude
said he was gonna do it like three years
ago
that dude yeah that dude was like I got
the stuff man I can do it and then he
made a big deal about it and then I did
here where's that mammoth where's the
mammoth park where's mammoth Zoo so
that's being worked on there's a couple
of different groups I think that are
working on it the question is you know
at what point do you call something a
mammoth
you know I mean we have so we have a
partially complete mammoth genome that
we can sort of splice with an elephant
genome that we can put into an elephant
egg that we can grow inside an elephant
and raised by humans in a world with no
other mammoths and with an environment
and and plant community it's very
different from where mammoths live so is
that a mammoth I mean we can you know
raise fuzzy elephants right is that is
that where where you land on the topic
you know you don't want me to do it how
do you feel you know I mean of course
there's like this
gee-whiz factor right like all of us
that that go into this field you know
that don't sort of grow out of it when
were four right like we were in it
partly because of that inspiration and
sort of cool factor of like wanting to
be transported back to this other time
so that's super compelling and from a
scientific standpoint I mean there are
certainly things to be learned the
justification that most people cite for
wanting to bring back a mammoth is that
it's going to serve some sort of
ecological function like you know there
used to be mammoths humans went and ate
them all and so now there are no more
mammoths in the Arctic and the Arctic
has lost all these important biological
functions I and and so that's
problematic on on a couple of levels
first of all you know it's not really a
mammoth second of all even if you bring
back the mammoths what about like all
those other things that aren't living
there anymore and how about the fact
that we're not in the Ice Age anymore
and and third for all of those resources
that you're going to be putting in to
try and bring back the mammoths maybe it
would be better to put those into
conserving the elephants so we don't
have to be trying to DX tink the
elephants and another 20 years I bet
there's a justification you know when
you're talking about let's keep the
elephants here instead of bringing the
mammoths back well if you brought a few
mammoths back there's a lot of people
who pay a lot of money to visit see or
on maybe ride
and a wooly mammoth yeah that's a lot of
money you could then put into you got a
you know saving the elephants in charge
500 bucks for a mammoth ride probably
now I don't advocate the exploitation of
mammoths I'm just saying this is a it's
like it it's probably an argument that's
been made like a lot more hair to grab
on to well I think what you're getting
at is the capitalist conservation irony
of you know you have to conduct your
science in the context of art culture
right so you've got to do it in a place
where a lot of people don't even really
care about science or don't her ignorant
of it believe things that are completely
counter to it but you still but you've
got to somehow get the funding that you
need to do the science that we all need
right but there's there's all kinds of
like irony's this is the fact that you
know most of I would assume that most of
like the excavations that you're a part
of or a lot of them are these oil and
gas companies too because they're the
ones that are digging all over the world
right and so you've got these guys who
are doing all kinds of horrible things
for our environment but they're all it's
also like your opportunity to learn
things about the environment like how do
you engage with that sort of irony no
that's a tough question but yeah I mean
you're right
especially in in sort of more rural
places like I do a lot of work in South
America a lot of fossils are found in
the extractive industries right they're
found in mines they're found on oil land
they're found I was on a project in
Guiana where they were finding bones
while they were washing away basically
the entire rainforest substrate and
looking for gold so you know they do
they do find a lot of fossils for us and
they call you in they imagine sometimes
they'll let you get stuff out do they do
that because they're obligated is there
like local laws that obligate them to
like okay we found a dinosaur we can't
just you know throw it in the
truck we have to like call scientists in
a lot of places there are what about the
black market like is there like are
there like completely just shady outfits
out there like fossil hunting and let
you kind of run in you can like run up
on them and like at a site and stuff is
that does it happen um I haven't
encountered it at any sites certainly
not at her pet sites because there's
been smell bad nobody wants them in
their house but i yeah i mean i mean
fossil hunting private collecting can be
you know certainly a problem for science
it can also be a boon for science it's
it's a complicated topic so i come out
of a school of thought that you know any
kind of support of the fossil collecting
industry is ultimately more bad than
good for science because it encourages
people who don't necessarily know what
they're doing don't necessarily have you
know the best interests interests of the
you know scientific community or the
fossils at heart to go out and find
stuff and then sell it for money right
um and we lose a lot of information that
way we don't know necessarily exactly
where that fossil came from we don't
know what else it was found with so we
lose a lot of the important information
that you would usually get for a fossil
oh I got something just to help with
this uh oh I think I know what he's done
good good well there's a couple of
choices there's a few things that you
might get
okay okay now yeah that's my Rhett
brought this in and we put it on a shelf
and you know what what I'm confiscating
it and I'm giving it to you I want you
to have it and I want you to learn
everything you can from it starting
right now yeah I feel bad about this got
that on the black market
well it looks like a cast of a
saber-tooth cat skull a cast it is a cat
the people at Restoration Hardware I
knew I known she said is that a it is
things that I'm doing this it is a cat
of a sabertooth yeah cat I don't know
what that means it's a cat of a cat so
what it tell us more it's a it's not as
all the fossil hunting rat has well it's
not a lot of times around when we die
yeah look around but what tell us about
Betty this is Betty
how do you know what first of all can
you look at this girl tell if it was a
male or a female no tell us about our
think skull it's been on our shelf so
you're right it's pretty accurate it's
um you know it's sort of frozen in its
mouth open position yeah I mean you can
tell that as it was incredibly long
teeth which scientists have spent a lot
of time mulling over and trying to
figure out the purpose of them and the
current thought is that it was used to
slash the jugulars of prey so we know
that saber-toothed cats these I Smilodon
and this species had their I had
extremely strong like beefy four limbs
and they would leap out and probably
wrestle prey to the ground and then
they'd use these sabers to to kill the
animal now these come out of the Tar
Pits right yeah we have more than 2,000
saber-tooth cats that we found at the
targets is that the largest I mean are
there more saber-tooth cats at the Tar
Pits than any other place oh absolutely
yeah by far right by far
why oh because
the Tar Pits the way they worked was you
have this asphalt bubbling out of the
ground because la is on top of oil
fields and it's tectonically active so
we have earthquakes and sometimes
fissures open up and the oil seeps up to
the ground and when the lighter hard
hydrocarbons evaporate from that you end
up with a sticky dense asphalt that
traps a bunch of things in it so what it
appears happened at the La Brea Tar Pits
is you would get I say a sticky pool and
it tends to get covered pretty quick
with you know leaves and and dirt and
you would see this you know I'm sure you
guys noticed this you know when you were
walking around the grounds of the Tar
Pits you have sort of these fenced off
areas where we have active tar seeps and
a lot of it you can't even see the tar
sieve that well because you've got plant
material on top of it so it seems that
what happened was occasionally a big
animal like a giant sloth or a mammoth
or a bison or a horse or a camel would
get stuck in one of these asphalt seeps
and when it was stuck it would of course
attract a lot of predators and so we
have two types of predators that are
super abundant at the Tar Pits we have
saber-tooth cats and we have dire wolves
and both of these white from Game of
Thrones like from Game of Thrones but a
lot smaller Oh same name though how big
were they they were like a sort of
bigger like beefier linebacker version
of a modern gray wolf okay um did you
know that like the Grateful Dead have a
song called dire wolf
that's about the La Brea Tar Pits no is
it good it's it's pretty good yeah I
mean okay I will see them live and they
stretch it out it'd be 30 minutes live
definitely I just can't get off of it so
those who get caught in that tar pit you
can't can't get out of it just got a
noodle your way I'm trying to make a
musical analogy I did it but the but
these dire wolves I see where you're
going and and the smile of Don's they
cannot resist this this pitiful huge
prey it's like why is it just sitting
there I can't it smells funny but I
gotta bite it I gotta get out there
right right and so you know going
act 2 the african ecosystem analogy so
normal african ecosystem you've got you
know like lots of elephant and zebras
and wildebeest and impala and giraffes
and and the big herbivore is walking
around then you have a smaller number of
like lions and cheetahs like the bigger
carnivores right liberate our pets is
exactly the opposite like we have a much
much much larger number of carnivores
than we have of herbivores it's like
this inverted pyramid of an ecosystem
and and that we think that's why we
think it was because you know one stuck
herbivore would attract a ton of
carnivores to eat ax and a whole bunch
of those guys would get stuck too and
they'd be like man Charlie's over there
look he's got it what oh now Dale's
going in there Charlie and Dale are both
over there I definitely got to get over
there I may eat Charlie and Dale too if
they're stuck yeah you know a next thing
you know is there's so many analogies
it's like you need to take your kids to
the Tar Pits and be like and leave them
and be like this is what when one of
your friends does something questionable
it's like getting stuck in a tar pit and
next thing you know you go over find out
about that you're stuck in the tar pit
of life and you're gonna die we're gonna
find you years from now and put y'all
display in a museum son don't do drugs
is there is excellent is there in like
the evolution of the saber-toothed I
mean yeah I guess the the saber-toothed
got bigger over time so can you see that
like if you go deep into the pit you see
like oh you got like really old
you got some normal non saber-toothed
cats well we do we have all kinds of
different cats but the Tirpitz they only
go back like fifty thousand years so
you're not gonna see major scene like a
snapshot evolutionary change in that but
the saber-tooth morphology itself
evolved a bunch of times when we
actually two different kinds of
saber-toothed cats in the Tar Pits the
main one is this one Smilodon Fatalis or
sometimes called some Smilodon
California's that's californica there's
like a Red Hot Chili Peppers album
by the Don californica but there's
another one called home aetherium that
sometimes referred to as the Scimitar
cat that had different shape sabers but
there's also there's been other
saber-tooth cats saber-tooth other
animals that were saber-tooth salmon
like back in the Maya scene up in Oregon
wow that's crazy right price to eat it
it's crazy
I would have thought that and the way
only the male's had it or something and
it was some sort of like you know mating
thing but they both that both males and
females have both males and females have
it yeah and then in addition to those
two saber-tooth cats in the Tar Pits
we've got the American lion which is the
biggest cat that's ever lived there were
these two lions one in Europe and one in
America and they were like the biggest
cats they're just enormous and we've got
a species of Jaguar subspecies of Jaguar
that's that's now extinct in North
America and then last but not least
we've got the mountain lion that's the
only one that just delete it yep
and how public-facing is your job are
you are you talking to people coming in
they're like are you are you in your
office most of the time you're in
research or like how often are you
interacting with just the public coming
to experience the Tar Pits you know it's
um on different occasions so so I mean I
I do public talks and and things like
that and I sometimes drive to Burbank to
do podcast interviews things like that
but occasionally you know when I go out
to the excavations to look at the site
and talk to the excavators and stuff you
know people are always coming by and
asking questions and I love that part of
my job where I get to just sort of you
know talk to people kind of informally
in that way too and and we do tours and
we had a summer camp recently that we
ran at the Tar Pits and I talked to the
summer campers and that was fun so so
there's a lot of kind of it's it's a
it's a very diverse job it's just it's
it's a lot right so something I'm
curious about and as you deal with the
public you know there's an interesting
dynamic in America where you've got a
very large percentage of people I don't
know I don't know
half or whatever they don't even believe
that evolution happened right are they
when you say oh these Tar Pits go back
fifty thousand years and they're like
well fifty thousand years ago there
wasn't anything like what is your being
an is such a crazy thing that we're
we're at the we know so much about all
the stuff that has happening you're
finding new and information all the time
but there's a lot of people who just
don't buy it so what is your interaction
with that like when you're when you're
interacting with the public you deal
with that kind of thing do you run into
that you know I haven't so far but I
know that we do get you know those sorts
of questions at the Tar Pits the the you
know gallery interpreter staff and and
some of the the lab and excavation staff
certainly certainly filled those types
of questions a lot I think you know one
of the advantages is that museums are
generally considered to be pretty
trusted institutions it's actually where
a lot of Americans get their scientific
information more than school more than
television shows they they actually
trust museums to give you know accurate
information about science and so I think
you know that's one of the big
advantages we have being such a public
and well-known institution is to try and
do that in a really profound way and and
a really sort of welcoming and open way
to try to explain concepts that some
people are really uncomfortable with
what are you what do you may be most
excited about in terms of a compelling
way to help people understand or I don't
know feel climate change when they when
they come in if that's if that's part of
your plans like how do you encapsulate
that you could turn the heat up
you could you could bring them into a
room and you could slowly turn the heat
up and it could be like did you know
that it raised two degrees centigrade in
the time that you were here and they'd
be like I didn't really notice it
doesn't feel that much different I guess
global warming is not really that big a
deal you don't want to do that because
people want have you thought of that
yeah people people want the thing I hear
people say that all the time they're
like one degree I mean like it was like
90 degrees yesterday and then like 95
the next day and it wasn't really that
big of a deal but don't do that idea
that was a bad one I was just the first
thing I thought of yeah I mean the
difference of like the difference of
five degrees average centigrade it
doesn't sound like much but that's the
difference between having half of North
America covered in ice and where we are
today right stuff like that see put that
on up t-shirt make it a little catchy er
but but but you but you are figuring out
specific ways to present that
information the facts in a compelling
way absolutely
that compels people to change their
minds or to appreciate or even take
action so what I guess what is the what
is the goal what's the how do you how do
you want to move the needle in like
visitors lives we want to change that's
the million dollar question that's
that's that's the sort of next three
years of my job there mm-hmm
I guess I mean you don't give it all
away than you I think I think you get
laid off you know I think I think at the
Tar Pits like you know we have the
ability to tell a story because of what
we have there but the the other thing
that we have there that you don't find
at most museums is we have the entire
process of a scientific discipline
happening in one place right so in one
visit I mean you you guys have been
there you know you can come and you can
see scientists paleontologists out in
the field finding fossils and excavating
them you can see those fossils same
fossils in the lab being worked on by
the by the lab preparers and being
researched by people at our museum and
visiting researchers from all over the
world and then you can see the
presentation of what we've learned from
that research in one place so I think
there's a real opportunity to sort of
empower people to think about how the
scientific process works which seems to
be something that's pretty mysterious
too a lot of people and foreign and
maybe even
a little bit threatening yeah and and
have people recognized oh this is just
the same type of empirical inquiry that
I do in my life everyday science is not
that mysterious everybody can do it
I can do it and now I have a better
understanding of you know why this is
important and why it is trustable yeah
and I mean it's exciting that you're
doing that because I mean I think the
the thing that you see quite a bit is
you'll see somebody who could go to a
place like the Tar Pits and they're like
oh that's yeah I get it mammoths fell in
there and that's cool and now their
bones are here and Sabretooth there's
that's a critical crazy animal that
existed at some point it doesn't exist
now but then as soon as you like suggest
something like well and that happened
fifty thousand years ago or this what
gives us this particular insight into
climate change or climate change or
evolution or whatever and all of a
sudden something that they hold sacred
is is threatened they put a wall up and
it's like well I'm not gonna go down
that trail that's and now you're getting
into some stuff that makes me feel
uncomfortable so and it's just a very
very difficult battle to be fighting but
a really really important one especially
in this country right so we commend you
I also come in here well I say I'm one
of the weak I said we men and I'm
excited yeah as we go back and visit to
see your work over the next few years as
you could I mean it was so exciting to
see people at work things happening
people wrestling with evidence and then
presenting it it's it was very cool but
you're not just there because you
recently came off of a trip to was it
Utah in Texas
yeah those both of those actually I
visited every state in the American
Southwest in two and a half weeks with
two small children whoa I feel pretty
good then you took two child scientists
with you yeah I mean all children are
basically scientists I think I mean your
children your children too I mean you
see someone like you know you know like
his children you tell the children you
took your children
I think I think if you see a child that
like throws a spoon off a table and
wants to see if it happens every single
time they do it that scientist okay
right so our lack of discipline
any more discipline in their lives so
what you find well so the the trip to
Utah was actually it was part of a
Natural History Museum trip it wasn't it
wasn't my research it was my first
dinosaur excavation it was really fun it
was a sauropod site so sore pods are
like the biggest dinosaurs you know like
what we used to call brontosaurus back
when I was a kid and so they had yeah I
mean huge like leg bones and and 40 Bowl
columns like the spines got the tail of
that thing we were just in the Natural
History Museum in New York couple weeks
ago and you know they had to like revise
the sauropod skeleton based on like the
posture of a 2009 findings or whatever
and one of the things they did was
extend the tail and the thing is its
comical how long it is it like gets to a
point where it definitely is like this
would be a really long tail and you'd be
like totally okay and then it like goes
another like 30 feet and to the point
where it's just these little teeny
vertebrae just in a line like a like
toothpicks just right next to each other
and like why'd you have to be so long
man God we get it you got a long tail
you you help dig one of these up yeah I
worry I worked at that site it was
really fun Wow was the head out yet we
had a couple of skull fragments and it
wasn't just sauropods we actually had a
jawbone from something some sort of meat
eater so might have been like an
Allosaurus or something we're not sure
where is this is it like in the middle
of nowhere Utah in like a State Park or
is it like beside a gas station are
people coming up moseying out of their
hotel rooms underdressed
no no LaBrea Tar Pits is one of the only
places I think where you're like right
in the middle of a major major urban
area no this is it was a little bit
middle of nowhere it was a couple hours
south in the lab beautiful country like
big sky crazy red rock formations nice
like really really gorgeous area to be
really hot you got to take a helicopter
in there like no we were able to drive
in with a with a hearty pickup truck and
like what are your kids thinking about
this when they're when they're they're
seeing you brush around so I wish my
four-year-old was a little bit more
excited about dinosaurs like most of his
peers I think I kind of spoiled it for
him because by giving him sort of overly
accurate scientific information from the
beginning because I asked him you know
when we were going I was like are you
excited to go you know dig up dinosaurs
you know what my dinosaurs were and he
looked at me I said yeah they were birds
which is true right which is true so or
rather Birds dinosaurs yeah so but you
know he was a good sport about it and
the baby you know he's just happy right
as long as as long as everything's you
know they're people around and and
things are changing and interesting he
couldn't be happier so right and what
about in Texas what was that what what
was coming out of the ground there so
that was actually related to my own
research it's back to back to the Ice
Age remember I said we have these two
species of saber-toothed cats at the Tar
Pits there's the the one that everyone
knows that was Smilodon and then there's
this other one with a scimitar cut home
aetherium this was a home etherion den
so there were like saber-toothed kittens
there were baby mammoths that the mama
saber-tooth had been dragging in for
their kittens it's got tons of fossils
it's actually I found it referred to
multiple times as the La Brea Tar Pits
of Texas so that's a place that we're
looking into maybe partnering with and
you know maybe I'll be doing some
research there with some other some
other scientists so you're gonna keep
going back there maybe maybe yeah so so
so those these were sort of my first
like kind of scouting expeditions for it
and we'll see we'll see what comes are
you like taking into account like the
nightlife in the area or like oh they
got a good barbecue restaurant down sit
down here like is it all about the cave
it's pretty much all about the case okay
I respect that
hey yeah I mean that's why you're a
scientist I like a good
barbecue recipe like a very good
barbecue clothes you see we could find
another cave that's my problem I got to
learn to subsist on like do you bring
your own food in there
like what are we talking alike
freeze-dried REI food like what's what's
happening good I need to prepare because
I I know that I'm gonna go on one of
these before I die
I got you well you know most most people
most paleontologists learn pretty
quickly like you know it's it's like
those saying an army runs on its stomach
right so so you've got a if you're gonna
have people working for you for not a
lot of money in harsh conditions and all
you got food uncertain whether we bring
we bring a lot of food
annal and and a fair amount of booze and
we feed people well and I really have a
good time like a it's almost like it's
catered like is there like a
is there somebody who's just there for
the food just some some digs run that
way you might want to you might want to
look into might be one of the one of the
boxes you want to check that's how you
get in I want you to date you can be a
hatered know the only way you're gonna
get in on it is to be the caterer I
doesn't be able to cook really well I'm
gonna bring a bunch of package you could
be this snack maybe it's not guy yeah I
mean it's not that guy coming around
tall guy all khakis coming around
granola he definitely looks like he
wants to be on big but he's just
bringing me Doritos right now that's the
only way you're getting in you got to
get a foot in the door and tail between
his legs delivering Doritos I didn't
know that the thing that was gonna burst
your bubble was not having a barbecue
restaurant nearby I just thought it was
gonna be just the shears or all the
hours of just brushing and chipping away
meticulous I think I think that's it
it's just like I would want to be the
guy that found something but I
understand that like most of the time
you're going to a place you're just
everything's a lot of stuff is already
found and you're kind of just like
getting more getting getting getting
more of it out well yeah I mean so
there's two types of paleo projects
right one is basically prospecting where
you're you're you're somewhere where you
know you should find fossils because
it's
the rocks are the right age because
people found fossils nearby and so
you're looking for a new site and then
other ones are people have found a site
and you know there's stuff there but you
don't know how far it goes you don't
know everything you're gonna find maybe
you need more of those specimens to kind
of figure out what was going on at the
site or learn more about those animals
and so those are the sites that that I
generally work at and I mean the Tar
Pits being the quintessential one right
like people have been excavating there
for more than a century
yeah thank you so and we're still
digging every day because we still feel
like there's there's more that we can
learn
maybe there's a business idea here so
you got people like me who just you know
I've got this interest in this subject
but I'm probably not gonna I'm obviously
not gonna go back and get the education
required to do this legitimately at this
point but I really want the tech to
experience the feeling of finding
something so Easter egg hunt think about
how that works right you got these
Easter eggs you place them all over the
back backyard and kids find them and you
know you can hide them a little more
difficult you make it little more
difficult to find for the older kids or
whatever mm-hmm what if you like you go
to one of these prospecting sites and
then you like you like you find that's
the thing that confirms that this is the
site and then you you cover back up and
you call me self ticket and you give me
and you're like listen the t-rex is like
over there you know like warmer yeah
give me a molder give me a map give me a
map that's not too difficult it's like
30 paces East you know you're not gonna
exit the treasure chest yeah yeah yeah I
just think I'm not written that I want
the feeling a but and I would paint good
money for this I think a lot of people
would start at the barbecue restaurant
take 48,000 pace here's the cool part
North once I find the t-rex you cover it
up and charge the next fool the same
amount that you charge me the t-rex you
know what I'm saying you
make a million bucks off on one t-rex
that you never completely dig up but
inside of my everything but by the way
I'm a full agreement we start this I
don't want to be involved you to start a
business like here's the thing you'd you
can you don't have to lie to anybody you
can tell them you're covering it up
every time I know that it's just people
don't people don't care about that don't
care what the satisfaction they just
want a they just want the experience and
they want everyone to rest
it's like west war as long as everyone
around plays along he discovered it he
did it let's all get back to the
barbecue right
you can charge an extra 20 bucks for air
horn rental so then when I find it I'm
like and they're like he's got talk a
key found it you know yeah yeah you know
what Rex Rex I'm Michael laughing you
know you could just come and volunteer
at the Tar Pits I guarantee you you will
find fossils every day and we've got a
hundred and fifty restaurants probably
within walking distance there's a lot of
really good eating in that area I can
can I send him over there and you'll
watch him for me yeah if he passes the
tests okay with the test okay yeah well
I'll tell you about the eye test is this
I get kicked off of rides cuz I'm too
tall my seven-year-old he bought the
little Lego Statue of Liberty when we
were in New York City and he brings it
back home and the there's a little Lego
flame that comes off of the Lego torch
of Lady Liberty which is a magnet we get
home and he drops the flame into the big
box of Lego's she lost she lost Italy
and I'm like yes I'm like extinct he was
upset he was he was crying and he comes
to me and I thought to myself I know how
to find this Lego torch I've seen the
painting intelligence grid it out lay it
all out grid it all out and meticulously
systematically over time
pour over every piece of the Legos until
they find the torch you didn't actually
do this with like string did you I
thought this and what I said was it's
gone son it's gone you lied to him well
he knew it was in there if he wants to
find it he can do it but I'm not gonna
sit there and do it I thought you were
out to tell her a wonderful story about
like putting them all out on like a
giant checkerboard and like going
meticulously through each square but you
told me what's gone that's my point
exactly man you go off and have your fun
or come to my house I got a job for you
it says you want me to come and find
your friggin lego there will be no
satisfaction in that but I will blow an
air horn when I find it so I respect
what you do for that reason because as
much as I love my son I couldn't even do
it for him others come volunteer I'll be
there at some point
just one day a week so we yes okay whoa
wow that has got a lot more serious for
the rest of your life yeah right okay
khakis provided as long as I can name
the thing after me there's a new species
how about that well just give it to him
straight you know so so we do if you
work in the fossil lab and you prepare a
skull which can take like months of
effort even even years potentially you
prepare an entire skull we let you name
the skull oh oh just that just that
skull we let you name like whatever
animal was associated with that skull so
so we've got you know fluffy we've got
said we've got little Timmy okay we've
got you know all kinds of individuals
but no whole species that's that that
you know so we're sort of again you know
once you've been working at the same
site for for what a hundred and twenty
years like you're not super likely to
find new species except now we're
starting to look at some of the smaller
animals that we find at the tar pit so
things like you know the rodents and the
rabbits and the lizards and stuff so
it's possible that in there we could
find
today I'm around news pieces the Rhett
Rhett you should name it something like
totally profane so no one feels
comfortable saying it just to test their
limit okay I'll do some thinking on that
well Emily thanks so much for coming and
talking to us yeah I still feel like
this is something I want to do you have
it you did it you got it ruined it
you haven't bursted my bubble burst it
you've just inflated it a little bit
well it was a pleasure being here
enjoyed talking to you guys yeah yeah
that's success man yeah all right run
along thanks for thanks for not you yeah
you tell em tell em Emily
run along to the tar pit okay I'll be
back I'll be happy to have you
[Music]